I went to Cal arts in the character
animation program and one of my teachers
was teehee theatre hehe went by te and
he was a governor of the Academy at the
time and he suggested after my third
year film that I submit it to the
Student Academy Awards I didn't even
know that there was a competition for
the student camping awards and so I
submitted it and lo and behold I want it
was a trip of a lifetime to go down and
spend a week with the all the other
winners from around the country Anna be
actually made lifelong friends with some
of these winners we got to go to
Hollywood studios to see movies being
shot we met with filmmakers John Landis
gave us a special tour himself of
universal studios he was shooting he was
doing pre-production on the blues
brothers at the time they treated us
like we were so special you know we were
all kind of looking at each other like
dudes were us not from somebody else I
can immediately entered my my senior
year project into the following year
hello behold I won again and I guess I
think I'm still to this day that the
only back-to-back winner of the student
cadmea ward and this the second year was
just as special it's one of the most
inspirational things that happened to me
in my entire career the student Kadim
awards I'll never forget that it's
something that every student filmmaker
should strive to get their film it into
so now come full circle and I like to
support the student Hemi words as much
as I can I try to see the films and vote
on them as an academy member but also
I've been a presenter I think twice and
as much as I can you know be there for
the student filmmakers and for the
Academy because I think it's one of
absolutely the great things the Academy
does